the jurogan experience
with the exception of carlin
no one was doing
the hourly thing he was the unusual
exception he was so unusual because he
was doing a new one every year
i always think it's so funny how carlin
is so revered
but uh obviously all comedians uh
respect him but like
during when he was around i don't think
he got enough
respect you know i mean he
he was probably appreciated for the
you know words you can't say on
television but like he was pumping out
some
really serious stuff yeah and i think
the audience didn't really like some of
the [ __ ] he was saying
i mean like yeah all these rich people
in the audience he's like we should turn
all the golf courses and give them to
homeless people people were like wait a
minute we paid to get in here
i mean yeah well he definitely had a lot
of counter culture in him you know a lot
of
rabble rouser and you know like he has
some great bits to this day that about
diseases that people keep reposting you
know yeah oh it's just it's there's not
a week on twitter where he doesn't have
some
uh
you know clip that really kind of
captures the moment how many specials
did he have let's just guess 15 i think
he had 20. 20. i think he did one for
every year at the peak of hbo
when hbo
to get a special on hbo
he was uh it was a standard
because and i remember i saw in an
interview
maybe this is
uh that
you know he tried the sitcom thing
and
they it didn't work so he stuck with
stan i don't know what the there's
there's carlin experts that were
probably
uh could explain a lot well he
he had some really good interviews and
god i wish he was alive while i was
doing the podcast where i could have
interviewed him and talked to him maybe
he was in the beginning what year did he
die
um
everything's a blur now everything was
six years ago or four years ago he died
like 11 2011 2008 2008 wow so it was
actually before the podcast so but if i
had the opportunity to talk to him i
would definitely talk to him about his
creative process but there's some pretty
good interviews where he talked about
that oh yeah no i remember i'm trying to
just turn off my phone because i'm an
idiot and i didn't turn it off before
look at all these specials yeah that's
unbelievable so he went he had some gaps
right like look at that 63 and then 67
and then 72 and then another one at 72.
god he had 2 and 72 and they won in 73
174 75 77
81 84. so what is the total number this
so for this uh
discography from maine i guess whatever
main means is uh
20 including that 2016 one so the 2016
one i kind of like it when a lot of
people die was supposed to be out on
2001 around september 11th
but it was literally scheduled to come
out right after september 11th and the
name of it i kind of like it when a lot
of people
that's [ __ ] obviously a bit of an
issue
yeah but so many uh hbs specialists i
don't know separate from that oh i
always thought it was every year
that's so interesting i thought it was
every year i felt like it was too
first 12 specials
huh
so those are hbo specials and what are
the other ones are those albums that
city i guess would be audio albums maybe
because there's also television and film
appearances in there scroll down scroll
down where you just had up tell where it
said tell scroll down so like what is
that television
oh okay though so these are different
okay and scroll down a little further so
these are all spots on television shows
and then scroll down a little further
and these are the hbo specials
and then written works and audio books
wow a lot a lot
yeah i know that he went through a
period he dealt with um i mean you
probably have interviewed kelly carlin
probably i haven't i've spoken there on
twitter i i don't i don't know her at
all but like i know that he struggled
with some addiction yeah and stuff like
that but he had a pill issue for a while
really yeah i remember i was i was
probably 93 i just started stand up and
he went on at the original improv on
44th street
and i remember he had a tape player
and he had a piece of paper where he you
know like a cassette recorder and he had
these notes and he had punch lines
underlined
i mean granted this is
30 years ago so maybe i'm remembering
some of it wrong but
i remember thinking god that is just
the detailing
was so impressive
that and you can see it in his writing
yeah i mean the the
the word smith
uh is just so extensive yeah he would
write out his entire special
word for word yeah and then he would
just kind of tighten it up yeah that's
how he did it and he would write sober
and then he would punch up on marijuana
it would smoke pot and punch it up wow
yeah that was his move brilliant i saw
him bomb
in front of my roommates
in new hampshire in 1988
yeah i think he went through uh rough
patch a couple of times in his career
i think with new material
you know it's like american stand-ups
versus like british stand-ups there is
you know there's such a necessity to
kill in america right like you can't be
bad for a moment that's why
i was so impressed when i saw chris rock
once at the comedy store just fearlessly
like what else what else and he didn't
get laughs for like 10 minutes and he's
like okay then he got off stage
completely unfazed like i would be like
[Laughter]
get me heroin something
and uh
but the whole thing of uh
carlin
uh just the volume was insane and also
you have to
you have to you have to risk bombing
yeah he didn't work out either like he
didn't go to comedy clubs and practice
that was actually part of one of his
routine he had this routine called uh
and [ __ ] this and it was like everything
was [ __ ] this and [ __ ] that and [ __ ]
comedy clubs he like he literally said
[ __ ] comedy clubs like i'm i don't have
to work out in comedy clubs and he would
just go and when i saw him in new
hampshire he went on stage with a legal
pad a yellow legal pad and he had all
his stuff written out and he put it down
and my roommate was like why is he
reading his jokes
i was like because they're new jokes
yeah [ __ ]